ja also ich begrüße zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns mit platons und theologie
befassen werden nachdem in der letzten
sitzung so ein paar einführende dinge
gesagt hatten
heute geht es also ganz verstärkt um
platon habe wie in jeder sitzung werde
ich zu beginn noch eine kurze
rückmeldung geben oder einen kurzen
rückblick geben auf die vergangene
sitzung und das war in diesem fall eben
immanuel kant sehen dann sich noch an
seine theorie der existenz es war ein
bisschen schwierig das war so ein
bisschen ja sehr verklausuliert was er
da gesagt hat
aber wir wollen dennoch uns noch mal
diesen diese sehr komplizierte zitat
hier anschauen das war das mit den 100
talern zieren sich noch diese 100 bloß
gedachte thaler und die 100 wirkliche
thaler wirklichen thaler das ist
natürlich ein gewisser unterschied und
ich wollte sie noch mal hier auf diese
rot markierte passage hinweisen ich lese
noch mal vor wenn ich also ein ding
durch welche und wie viele prädikate ich
will selbst in der durchgängigen
bestimmung durchgingen durchgängige
bestimmungen bedeutet in jeder hinsicht
also dieses ding vollkommen bestimme in
jedem möglichen eigenschaften die dieses
ding haben kann wenn ich denke so kommt
dadurch dass ich noch in zusätze dieses
ding ist also man könnte auch sagen
dieses ding existiert nicht das mindeste
zudem dinge hinzu denn sonst würde nicht
eben dasselbe sondern mehr existieren
als ich im begriffe gedacht hatte
begriffe ist jetzt die essenz all das
wesen und so könnte nicht sagen könnte
ich nicht sagen dass gerade der
gegenstand meines begriffs existiere ja
das war der punkt dass wir gesagt hatten
existenz ist nicht ein prädikat wie es
zum beispiel die farbe grün ist oder das
gewicht ist und auch nicht die anzahl
ist
sondern das ist ihr so eine art
rahmenbedingungen die wir um dieses ding
um dieses wesen herum legen wir können
als rahmen oder auch modalität kann man
genauso einen eben sagen ein ding ist
möglich das ist also das gedachte dem
wir können sagen es ist wirklich ist
existiert wirklich aber diese
modalitäten betreffen nicht die essenz
des ding ist nach kann zumindest also
nicht sein wesen so nur eben die mehr
oder weniger die rahmung wie ich das
ding präsentieren kannte ist aber
natürlich ein spezieller denke das heißt
nicht dass er unbedingt recht haben muss
es gibt viele andere denkerinnen und
denker des mittelalters zb die das ganz
anders als cannes gesehen hatten die
eben wie zum beispiel thomas von der
queen sagten dass existenz schon so eine
art eigenschaft von dingen ist und
genauso kann man sich fragen existieren
dinge wenn es prädikat ist die existenz
mehr oder weniger also können dinge
besonders intensiv existieren und dinge
bisschen weniger existieren und das
führt uns jetzt zum denker der heutigen
sitzung nämlich zu platon der eben
gerade so denkt na das ist gerade so
dieser punkt bei platon wie sehen sie
ihn mal so sieht er aus natürlich sind
das alles gewisse stilisierungen ich
denke mal so diese ersten beiden hier
die sind recht authentisch aber diese
anderen zb also jetzt das recht hier das
ist natürlich nur ein gemälde das ist
das ist klar dass das nicht dass das
nicht ganz zutreffend essen das ist eine
stilisierung von von platon und ich gebe
ihnen auch noch mal kurz die daten durch
wann er gelebt hat also man vermutet
also so geboren wurde 428 oder 427 vor
christus
und eben gestorben ist dann 348 oder 47
vor christus jetzt haben wir noch ein
teilnehmer so genau also das ist das ist
der plan und mit dem wollen wir uns
heute beschäftigen das ist jetzt der
heutige held unserer sitzung und wir
wollen einfach mal die immer diesen
denker unter gewissen leitfragen
betrachten und diese leitfragen sind
jetzt folgende wir haben uns ein paar
überlegt also ich wie sie wissen ich
gebe immer so ein paar leitfragen zu
beginn inwiefern existieren nach platon
dinge auf verschiedene weise bzw in
verschiedenen graden
da würde könnte natürlich sagen ein ding
existiert oder ist existiert nicht aber
es existiert nicht in verschiedenen
graden platten denkt dass und das ist
die so genannte comparatives tische und
theologie komparatistik bedeutet sie
kennen alle das fach komparatistik also
vergleichend also es können dinge
existieren mehr oder weniger als es
andere dinge tun
das ist also die sogenannte comparatives
tische und theologie was unter logi ist
erkläre ich auch noch nachher ist die
lehre vom seien dann wie verhalten sich
die verschiedenen existenz stufen
zueinander
ja das ist eine spannende frage wenn
jetzt dingen ab platon auf verschiedene
weise existieren in verschiedenen graden
oder verschiedenen stufen wie verhalten
sich dann diese verschiedenen stufen
zueinander dieser dinge bekannt hat
dieses problem nicht weil für ihn
existiert alles auf dieselbe weise für
platon eben nicht eine weitere frage die
wir behandeln wollen ist welche probleme
gehen mit platons und theologie einher
sie können sich schon überlegen es ist
immer schwierig wenn man dinge in
verschiedenen hinsichten mehr oder
weniger existieren lässt aber dann
bekommen wir in die welt der dinge noch
viele weitere ontologische
unterscheidungen damals viel einfacher
wenn man sagen etwas existiert
oder es existiert nicht aber nicht ins
auf verschiedene weise oder in mehr oder
weniger intensiven geraten
das wäre zum beispiel so ein problem das
wollen wir dann in der
abschlussdiskussion heute versuchen zu
klären
ja und dann eben eine allgemeinere frage
wie was ist der unterschied zwischen
anthologie den begriff habe ich jetzt
schon mehrmals verwendet zb hierbei
platons ontologie und metaphysik
sie haben den begriff auch schon mal
gehört mit physik ich arbeite zb einem
lehrstücke und theologie und metaphysik
und viele forscherinnen und forscher
philosophien philosophen aber auch
sonstige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler würden diese begriffe
synonym gebraucht würden sagen da kann
ich gar keinen unterschied erkennen
zwischen unter lobby und metaphysik das
ist dass hilfe ist es gar nicht so
leicht diesen unterschied fest zu machen
diese unterschied betrifft aber eben
unsere frage nach dem was es heißt zu
existieren nach theorien der existenz
also darauf möchte ich heute der
einführung auch noch kurz eingehen
so jetzt habe ich ihn geschickt das
letzte mal eine ein text und zwar aus
diesem thema platon handbuch und zwar
ist das sehr sehr sehr sehr lohnenswert
dieses dieses buch und es ist ganz
einfach sie haben zugang zu diesem buch
nämlich über ihren account über ihren b
account mit ihrer campus lmu adresse
können sie sich über den opa katalog
digital dieses handbuch ganz legal
herunterladen kann ich ihnen sehr
empfehlen daraus ist auch dieser
abschnitt über platons unter logi den
ich ihnen geschickt hatte
darin finden sich auch noch viele
weitere interessante aufsätze zu
verschiedenen themen der ganzen der
ganzen wirke so und jetzt steht eben in
diesem handbuch folgendes also jetzt zur
frage nach der und logie das wort
ontologie leitet sich von den
griechischen ausdrücken
partizip neutrum von er hinein
griechisch sein sein und logos rede
erklärung ab und bezeichnet den zweig
philosophischer forschung der primär auf
die beantwortung der fragen zählt
erstens was scientist also griechischen
und zweitens was das seiende ist das
tollste artikel das seite ist und die
frage die ich jetzt fett markiert hier
was das eine ist das ist eigentlich die
frage unseres seminars unsere frage ist
nicht so sehr was alles scientist also
ist jetzt ein schatten sein oder ist
jetzt eine idee sein das ist zwar eine
interessante frage aber die interessiert
uns in unserem seminar nicht so sehr wie
die zweite frage was das seiende ist
also was bedeutet es überhaupt für ein
ding zu sein
oder setzt sich nicht schon in dem ich
von dinge spreche dass es existieren wir
sehen diese frage ist noch viel
komplizierter oder viel tiefer als die
erste also diese zweite frage wollen wir
uns vor allem im laufe dieses semesters
stellen
mit der ersten frage mit dir was sein
ist wird danach gefragt was zum sein
denn gehört das heißt welche arten von
entitäten es gibt ideen schattenbilder
einzel dinge mit der zweiten frage
danach was es heißt ein sein das zu sein
das heißt was es heißt zu existieren bzw
eine entität zu sein
das ist genau die frage die im zentrum
unseres seminars stehen soll
das wäre eine sehr interessante
unterscheidung häufig wirft man ja alles
in einen topf aber das doch sehr
differenziert diese rede über ökologie
und jetzt lese ich noch ein bisschen
weitere zitate voraus diesem sehr
instruktiven artikel aus diesem platon
handbuch eine ökologisch relevante
antwort auf die erste frage besteht
darin die begriffe aufzudecken und
expliziten mit denen die gesamtheit
dessen was es gibt auf erhellende weise
in umfassendste klassen von entitäten im
folgenden und theologisch fundamentale
klassen eingeteilt werden kann
die in einer solchen antwort enthaltenen
begriffe traditionell auch kategorien
mögen entweder als die verschiedenen
bedeutungen verstanden werden in denen
der ausdruck entität auf dinge
verschiedene ontologisch von der
metaller klassen zutrifft oder als die
dem gattungsbegriff der entitäten
mittelbar untergeordneten art begriff
also diese erste frage betrifft
kategorien also einteilung von
verschiedenen dingen die existieren und
jetzt gibt es eben dann die zweite
fragen ob der versucht das verhältnis
der einzelnen kategorien zum begriff der
entität zu klären führt auf die zweite
und theologische grundfrage die frage
was es heißt zu existieren mit ihrer
beantwortung soll nicht nur geklärt
werden ob zu existieren für alle
entitäten ein und dasselbe bedeutet oder
verschiedenes für entitäten verschiedene
und theologische fundament aller klassen
mit ihr soll auch geklärt werden welche
bestimmungen darin enthalten sind zu
existieren und wie diese seit dem
mittelalter auch transzendentalen
genannten bestimmungen ihrerseits zu
expliziten sind also die zweite frage
interessiert uns mehr
und jetzt das ist jetzt eine
entscheidende frage jetzt kann man sich
fragen was ist der unterschied zwischen
ontologie das ist also die lehre von dem
sein denn das ist ein griechisches wort
und ontos ist dass sein de und locker
scannen sie es die lehre und metaphysik
das ist also die lehre von dem was über
die physik hinausgeht meter heißt
griechisch über hinaus und physik ist
eben die physik oder dasjenige was
vergeht und entsteht das ist ein
aristotelische begriff beziehungsweise
dieser begriff wurde erst im anschluss
an aristoteles geprägt was ist der
unterschied
und es wird diese die die frage führt zu
einer anderen frage was ist der
unterschied zwischen der metaphysiker
generals und der metaphysiker spezialist
das ist eine unterscheidung die im
mittelalter und immer jünger dann
zentral wurde und die metaphysiker
general ist also die generelle die
allgemeine metaphysik die kann man auch
synonym mit ontologie für
also die fragen nach dem was sein dass
generell als solches ausmacht das ist
die ontologie und die kategorien zum
beispiel ja also bei aristoteles haben
sie bestimmt schon gehört aristoteles
hat eine kategorien lehre also die
quantität die qualität die relation die
modalität usw
das sind alles ganz allgemeine
bestimmungen des sein denn die betreffen
die ontologie also die metaphysiker
general ist und davon kann man doch
diese fragen der metaphysiker spezialist
abgrenzen das sind traditionell die
rationale theologie die rationale
psychologie und die rationale kosmologie
die rationale theologie stellt eben die
frage nach dem höchsten sein denn nicht
nachdem sein denn allgemein sind im
höchsten seine das ist gott der
tradition die rationale psychologie
stellt die frage nach der seele
nach der unsterblichkeit der seele und
die rationale kosmologie stellt die
frage nach der welt was die welt
überhaupt ist das ist also eine ganz
sinnvolle unterscheidung und jetzt
bezogen auf die frage von vorhin was
jetzt der unterschied zwischen und
theologie und metallphysik ist würde ich
sagen und theologie meint einfach dass
sein die in all in allgemeiner hinsicht
als in seinen grundstrukturen während
die metaphysik er konkrete fragen das
seien dann betrifft als eben zum
beispiel gott die seele oder auch die
die welt also konkrete frage nach der
existenz bestimmter dinge ausgezeichnete
dinge das ist könnte man die metaphysik
nennen aber die unterscheidung ist nicht
ganz klar aber das wollte ich ihn
einfach mal zu beginn auch noch sagen
okay und jetzt kommen wir also auf
platon zu sprechen ich möchte ihnen
jetzt eingangs ein paar wichtige zitate
von platon hier präsentieren also es
gibt die ganz bekannte unterscheidung
von zwei welten bei platon die kennen
sie alle haben sie schon mal gehört die
sogenannte zwei welten lehre und die
betrifft natürlich die erste frage was
scientist
die betrifft nicht so sehr die frage was
etwas zum seinen macht sondern ihr was
wie geordnet werden kann
kategorisiert werden kann und das sagt
jetzt platon bzw der platonische
sokratis in diesem dialog von hier unten
sehen sie die angabe dass ist die
stephanus paketierung als wenn sie eine
hausarbeit dann platon zitieren immer
nach dieser stefano situations weise das
heißt das ist eine ziffer und dann gibt
es einen buchstaben und dann gibt es
hier noch die zeilennummern danach
sollten sie platon zitierten jetzt sagt
hier diese sokrates in diesem dialog
fördern sollen wir dann zwei arten des
seienden behaupten die eine art sichtbar
die andere unsichtbar
das sollten wir behaupten sagte er diese
andere dialogpartner quiz und das
unsichtbare als immer sich gleich
verhalten das sichtbare aber als niemand
niemals sich gleich verhalten
auch das sollten wir behaupten sagte er
also hier gibt es jetzt zwei arten des
sein denn das eine ist sichtbar das sind
also die dinge wie sie in der welt zu
existieren tische bäume stühle der
computer vor ihnen
das ist der sichtbare seite und dann
gibt es eine andere orte seien dann
nehme ich das unsichtbare sein
und jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
was ist denn jetzt das unsichtbare seine
sie ahnen es schon das geht jetzt so ein
bisschen in die richtung der idee
zumindest ist die idee nicht durch
unsere normalen sinneswahrnehmung sind
es organe wahrnehmbaren das wäre jetzt
praktisch so eine unterscheidung
zwischen zwei klassen von sein denn
sowas finden wir bei platon aber es geht
natürlich auch noch weiter es wird noch
ein bisschen komplexer wir haben nicht
nur zwei welten sondern es gibt da noch
zwischenstufen zwischen diesem bloß
sichtbaren und dem bloß intelligent dem
für die augen unsichtbar und das
betrifft jetzt platons sogenannte
comparatives tisch und logie ich habe
schon einleiten gesagtes meint einfach
die ontologie die lehre vom seinen die
verschiedene intensität gerade des sein
denn kennt es gibt dinge die existieren
mehr und es gibt dinge die existieren
weniger nach platon und das liegt so ein
bisschen die these nahe dass ex ist
nach platon fast so was wie ein prädikat
ist ja weil oder ein prädikat jetzt im
sinne grammatikalische und adjektiv also
etwas ist so und so schauen sie
komparatistik bedeutet was können sie
denn kooperieren ja sie können eben
adjektive kooperieren ja also grün
grüner am grünsten oder reich reiche am
reichsten und so spricht jetzt platt
oder zumindest so kann man das
interpretieren eben vom sein denn als
das seite ist wie ein adjektiv und oder
philosophisch gesprochen wie ein
prädikat das man eine sache zu spricht
ja also das heißt nicht alles existiert
im selben grad und auskunft über diese
comparatives tische und theologie die
gibt platon sogenanntes linien gleichen
ist dieses gleichnis habe ich ihnen
zusammen mit dem höhlengleichnis und dem
sonnen gleichnis in der letzten e mail
zugeschickt und jetzt will ich da ihnen
einfach noch ein paar sachen vorlesen
aus dieser comparatives tischen und
theologie aus diesem linien gleichnis
also sagte sokrates sohn im nun wie von
einer in zweigeteilten linie die
ungleichen teile also eine linie wird in
zwei ungleiche teile getrennt und teile
wiederum jeden teil nach demselben
verhältnis das geschlecht des sichtbaren
also geschlecht meint die arzt die
gattung des sichtbaren und dass das
denkbaren so gibt ihr vermögen des
verhältnisses von deutlichkeit und
unbestimmtheit in dem sichtbaren der
eine abschnitt bilder
ich kenne aber bilder zuerst die
schatten dann die erscheinung im wasser
und die sich auf allen dichten glatten
und glänzenden flächen finden und alle
der gleichen wenn du es verstehst ich
verstehe es sagte dialogpartner und als
in anderen abschnitt setzte das gm diese
gleichen nämlich die tiere bei uns und
das gesamte gewächs reich und alle arten
des künstlich gearbeiteten das setze ich
sagte ja
wirst du auch die sache selbst behaupten
wollen sprache ist sprach ich das in
bezug auf wahrheit und nicht wie sich
das vorstellbare von dem erkennbaren
unterscheidet so acht jahren das
nachgebildete von dem
welches nachgebildet ist das möchte ich
gar sagte er
also wir haben jetzt in der ersten stufe
dieses linie gleichen ist es mit bloßen
bildern zu tun also mit spiegelbildern
mit illusionen ja so kann man sich das
vorstellen wie wenn sie eben jetzt in
eine pfütze blicken und dann sehen sie
darin irgendwie ein gegenstand dann
würden sie ja wahrscheinlich wir
diskutieren nach er jetzt gleich noch
drüber würden sie bestimmt nicht sagen
dass da jetzt ein auto in der pc ist
oder dass ich irgendwann bestimmter
gegenstand in der pfütze jetzt befindet
nee überhaupt nicht in der kürze wird
der gegenstand nur gespiegelt oder
repräsentiert auch eine ganz falsche
weisen aber er ist nicht in der pfütze
sind die pfütze spiegelt uns diesen
gegenstand nur vor
ok weitergeht so betrachten und auch die
teilung des denkbaren das wäre also nach
diesem zitat aus dem feinde und von
folien das nicht sichtbare das ist das
denkbare wie dies zu teilen ist zu
teilen heißt hier gibt es wieder unter
logische unterschied im intensität grad
wonach also sofern den einen teil die
seele genötigt ist indem sie das damals
abgeschnittene als bilder gebrauch zu
suchen von voraussetzungen aus nicht zum
anfang zurück schreitend sondern nach
dem ende hin den anderen hingegen auch
von voraussetzungen ausgehend aber zudem
keiner voraussetzung weiter bedürfen den
anfang hin und in dem sie ohne die bei
jenem angewendeten bilder mit den
begriffen selbst verfährt
dieser sagte er was du erklärst habe ich
nicht gehörig verstanden so werden auch
gegangen beim ersten lesen das denkbare
ist viel komplizierter als das sichtbare
unterteilt danach aber sprachlich denn
wenn folgendes noch voraus voran
geschickt ist wirst du es leichter
verstehen denn ich denke du weißt dass
die welche sich mit dem es kunst und den
rechnungen und dergleichen abgeben dass
gerade und ungerade und die gestalten
und die drei arten der winkel und was
dem sonst verwandt ist in jeder
verfassungsrat voraussetzen
nachdem sie dies als wissen zu grunde
gelegt keine rechenschaft weite darüber
weder sich noch andere geben zu dürfen
glauben
als sei dies schon allen deutlich
sondern hiervon beginnt gleich das
weitere ausführen und dann voll
gerechterweise bei dem an langen auf
dessen untersuchung sie ausgegangen
waren
allerdings sagte er dies ja weiß ich
also damit ist jetzt die geometrie
gemeint also die mails kunst und auch
die arithmetik das ist also die
rechnungen die da angestellt werden die
machen selbst wiederum voraussetzungen
die sie selbst nicht einholen können
also zum beispiel die geometrie muss den
begriff des winkels voraussetzen nach
platon jetzt nach oder die idee der
strecke voraussetzen
die kann sie aber selbst nicht wieder
einholen sind die muss sie eben
voraussetzen wie auch die arithmetik die
zahlen und so weiter all das sind
praktisch bediente in theley gewissen
schafften das ganz entscheidend auch
dass sie sich der sichtbaren gestalten
bedienen und immer auf diese ihre reden
beziehen die geometrie bezieht sich eben
auf bestimmte konkrete gegenstände
zumindest denkt dass platon zu natürlich
ist die heutige geometrie völlig
abstrakt wie wir sie heute verstehen und
erachtet sie nicht von diesen handeln
sollen von jenen die ihm diese gleichen
und um das des vierecks selbst willen
und seiner diagonale ihre beweise führen
nicht um das wählen welches sie zeichnen
und so auch sonst überall dasjenige
selbst was sie nachbilden und abzeichen
wovon es auch schatten und bilder im
wasser gibt deren sie sich zwar als
bilder bedienen
immer aber jenes selbst zu erkennen
trachten was man nicht anders sehen kann
als mit dem verständnis also verständnis
meint intellektuell ein sind du hast
recht sagte ja diese dialogpartner von
sokrates diese gattung also sagte ich
sogar das allerdings sei auch
erkennbares die seele aber sei genötigt
beide untersuchungen derselben sich der
voraussetzung zu bedienen nicht so da
sie zum anfang zurück geht weil es sich
nämlich über die voraussetzung hinauf
nicht versteigen kann sondern so dass
sie sich dessen als bilder bedient was
von den anderen dingen dargestellt wird
und zwar derer die im vergleich mit den
anderen als hell und klar verherrlicht
und in ehren gehalten werden ich
verstehe sagt er
dass du meinst was zur geometrie und den
ihr verwandten künstler alle die
geometrie die hat es immer so ein
bisschen mit konkreten bildern zu tun
und die muslime voraussetzen wie zum
beispiel strecken vielleicht auch zahlen
winkel und so weiter die sie selbst
nicht mehr zum gegenstand hat sagt
platon so verstehe denn auch dass ich
unter dem anderen teil des denkbaren das
ist dann packt der kleinere abschnitt
oder der größere wie auch immer
da ist eine gemeine was die vernunft
unmittelbar ergreift indem sie mittels
des dialektischen vermögens
voraussetzungen macht nicht als anfänger
sein wahrhaft voraussetzung als ein
schritt und anlauf damit sie bis zum
aufhören aller voraussetzungen an den
anfang von allem gelangen diesen
ergreifen und so wiederum sich an alles
haltend was mit jenem zusammenhängt zum
ende hin absteige ohne sich überall
irgendetwas sinnlich wahrnehmbaren soll
nur der ideen selbst an und für sich
dazu zu bedienen und so am ende eben zu
ihnen den ideen gelangen das ist jetzt
der unterschied also wir haben
einerseits die geometrie und die
arithmetik die hat es mit voraussetzung
zu tun die sie selbst nicht wieder
einlösen kann und jetzt unterscheidet
ihren platten hier die vernunft die ein
dialektisches vermögen hat was auch
immer das jetzt genau ist müssen wir
noch genau erklären und diese
voraussetzungen die kann sie wieder
einholen
indem sie da eben zu diesen ideen
gelangte die den letzten gründen die
alles von dir 'nen alles verständlich
machen
ich verstehe sagte er zwar noch nicht
genau denn du scheinst mir ja viele
leute zu sagen doch aber dass du
bestimmen willst was vermittelt der
dialektischen wissenschaft von dem sein
denn und denkbaren geschaut werde sei
sicherer als was von den eigentlich so
genannten wissenschaften deren anfänge
voraussetzungen sind welche dann die
betrachtenden mit dem verstanden und
nicht mit dem sinn betrachten müssen
weil sie aber ihre betrachtung nicht so
anstellen dass sie bis zu den anfängen
zurück gehen
sondern nur von den annahmen aus so
scheinen sie dir keine vernunft kenntnis
davon zu haben obgleich gehe man von
anfang an aus sie ebenfalls erkennbar
wären verstand aber scheinst du mir die
fertigkeit der mess künstler und was dem
ähnliches zu nehmen als etwas zwischen
der bloßen vorstellung und der vernunft
erkenntnis zwischen innen liegendes aha
also es geht jetzt um die vernunft
erkenntnis die ist auf die ideen bezogen
auf das was den allerersten anfang macht
und davon kann man die vernunft für die
verstandes erkenntnis noch unterscheiden
die eben also hier der verstand der eben
nur die fertigkeit der mess künstler und
der geometer usw betrifft die immer
voraussetzung machen müssen die sie
selbst nicht einholen können vollkommen
richtig sprach ich du hast du es
aufgefasst und nunmehr auch die diesen
vier teilen zugehörigen zustände der
seele dazu die vernunft einzig dem
obersten die verstandes gewissheit dem
zweiten dem dritten aber weil sie
glauben also glauben jetzt nicht im
theologischen sinne sondern die
vermutung mehr oder weniger und dem
vierten die wahrscheinlichkeit und
ordnet ihr nach dem verhältnis das so
viel dass worauf sie sich beziehen
an der wahrheit teil hat soviel auch
jedem von ihnen gewissheit zu kommen
ich verstehe sagt er und räume ist ein
und ordnete sie wie du sagst
so also das war jetzt natürlich sehr
dicht gedrängt das ist immer schwierig
bei platin die besetzung ist auch immer
ein problem aber jetzt sehen sie hier
mal eben das sogenannte höhlengleichnis
wir gehen nach einer diskussion noch ein
bisschen genauer mit ein das wird das
nachverfolgen können sie sehen hier
unten bloße schatten und dann sehen sie
hier die gegenstände von denen die
schatten eben die schatten sind dann
sehen sie ein feuer und es ist
letztendlich so angeordnet dass der
erkennende einen weg hinauf beschreiten
muss bis er dann praktisch die sonne
sieht hier aber gar nicht drauf ist die
sonne ist dann stellvertretend für die
idee die das eigentlich sein de ist und
hier sehen sie jetzt sehr schön gemacht
ist aus dem dtv lexikon philosophie
das ist natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt
für universitäre zwecke geeignet aber
zur veranstaltung anschaulich und finde
ich es ganz gut hier sehen sie jetzt
dieses linien gleichnis auf dieses
höhlengleichnis bezogen und zwar fangen
mal unten an hier unten haben wir nur
diese bilder das ist das im geringsten
maße seine wie zum beispiel jetzt in
einer pfütze
ob wir hier oben haben wir ja schon die
pfütze aber das ist praktisch der
schatten eines bloßen eine bloße
illusion eines losen oder auch als busen
gegenstandes sie sehen sie die bilder
dann sehen sie gewisse lebewesen und
gegenstände interessant dass platt und
die lebewesen also tiere mit den
gegenständen irgendwie gleich zu setzen
scheint dann haben wir die sonne oder
das feuer das eben die bedingung für
diese schatten ist dann geht es weiter
in dieser comparatives tischen und
theologie dann bekommen wir die
mathematischen gegenstände das sind also
die verstandes wissenschaften wie zum
beispiel eben die geometrie die
arithmetik die selbst eben von zahlen
ausgehen muss zahlen als entitäten als
die annehmen muss die sie selbst nicht
einholen kann
zum beispiel kann man auch sagen nach
ulk lied gewisse aktionen die auf denen
die arithmetik und geometrie basiert
diese axiome diese grundsätze diese
mathematischen die werden von dem
mathematik selbst nicht wieder eingeholt
die werden einfach vorausgesetzt
und deswegen sind auch diese eben diese
im mathematischen entitäten nicht so ex
so intensiv sein wie es die ideen sind
das sind die allerletzten gründe und
dann kennt eben platte noch was und es
ist dann die idee des guten die ist
jetzt in unserem text den wir gelesen
haben nicht vorgekommen aber das ist
dann auch noch mal eine ganz besondere
entität weil darüber diskutieren wir
jetzt auch noch gleich ein bisschen
weiter weil nämlich die sonne oder die
idee des guten
die bedingung der möglichkeit ist für
alles an
also wir können nur diese verschiedenen
dinge erkennen wenn wir zugang zu dieser
idee des guten haben die ist praktisch
der grund der erkenntnis grund aber auch
der science grund diese anderen dinge
das kompliziert diese platonische und
theologie noch mal ganz entschieden